Karissa thank you so much for joining me
here today I want to ask you a little
bit about your chess upbringing so I
started when I was in elementary school
so I was seven when I first um started
playing tournament chess but I first was
interested in it when I was six um
there's like a flyer for the school
chess club and it met like before school
in the mornings and I really wanted to
to go and play uh but the problem was
like they didn't have any instructors
there it was just like to go and play
with each other I had no idea how the
pieces moved nothing um and so my
parents were just like ah it's okay
don't join the club and I was like okay
um and then like the year after I was
like Mom Dad can I join chess club and
then they were like oh this is something
that you know maybe she's like really
interested in and so my dad first taught
himself how to play and like how pieces
moved and stuff and then taught me um
and we used to play all the time when I
was a kid just like on the floor in the
living room
and I was always trying super hard to
beat him never really could until one
day a few months later um but yeah and
since we played so much eventually he
got like really tired of it and he was
like one night he's just like I'm just
going to take you to like a actual chess
club and that was where I played my
first tournament was there something
specific or a specific person that
influenced you most or you looked up to
the most as you were growing up yeah so
definitely my dad was up there we spent
so many hours just like playing chess
together um you know I was always like
really fighting and struggling to beat
him which I think is probably where like
that Spirit comes from for me um another
big influence was when I was starting
out um I played in one Club Whata chess
club and I remember so it met like every
Wednesday night and it would be like one
game a night it would be like one of
those uh month-long tournaments sort of
situations and everyone there was super
nice um I was the only kid there but
after all my games um they' always
offered to like analyze it with me we'
go over all the moves and like all the
club members would be there and like
offering suggestions and helping me
improve my chest and they've also been
like a great source of support nice so
was there something specific that
attracted you to the game I think the
first time I was like really to chess
was when I was at my school chess club
and I was playing um a friend and this
friend was like probably the smartest
person I knew at the time she still is
like super smart maybe still the
smartest person I know um and we were
playing chess and I beat her like three
times in a row to be fair we weren't
really playing with um actual chess
rules it was like this idea that if you
put the king in check and the other
person didn't notice and you just take
the king and win I so doesn't really
count but I beat her three times in a
row and I was like wao maybe this is
something that I'm like kind of good at
I see and since then you went to college
you're combining chess and college and
recently you became World um Junior Vice
Champion for girls um how were you able
to balance your schoolwork and chess and
coming back to chess I know you had this
short period of time where you didn't
play as much yeah so um my school is
actually on the quarter system which is
super convenient because it doesn't
start until really late September almost
October really late um and so I wasn't
missing um too many too much of uh my
academic work when s of playing these
tournaments but this is actually the
first tournament where I'll be like um
Missing full weeks of school along with
uh playing chess so we'll see how that
goes so this is the first time so I
can't ask you how you're balancing
everything but hopefully you did you did
a good job and planning everything so
that you don't have exams during the
event yeah no exams during uh just
homework and stuff like that and uh last
question for you Karissa I was wondering
if uh you are doing any other ex
extracurricular activities in your
University besides you know working on
chess and going to school nope
nothing nothing interesting no yeah well
I'm really looking forward to seeing you
back on the over the board I know you
haven't played last year so can't wait I
can't wait to see um how how you're
going to do thank you good luck thank
[Music]
you